okay I think that's working now hello
YouTube this there is my zip there I
don't know if you can see it I brought
it with me who of course you can see you
can see that thing from space the wonder
of shooting a cellphone video in broad
daylight when it's not a transgender
makeup tutorial certain to make the
YouTube trending list oh I should have
turned to notifications off no I'm just
a just a regular run-of-the-mill basic
[ __ ] cisgender male shooting an
unflattering broad day like raking
across my problem skin I know a lot of
you clicked this because of the the
title and that's that's not clickbait
it's been a legitimate question for for
a while now and some things have have
heated up some some plans here have
changed that we'll be updating you a
little bit more on tomorrow my
half-asian Larry bill Richman will be in
also by the way would talk more about
Donald Trump in the Ukraine at the time
of recording this video I'm still
reading the documents that have been
released to try and have a more informed
opinion on it oh by the way I know I did
aggress here but can you see this look
at this I've had this gimbal this whole
time for my my phone did I pay for an I
didn't even realize it I was holding
this up with my shoulder like an idiot
anyway well we'll talk about Donald
Trump in Ukraine tomorrow and how about
that Greta huh
I don't want to talk about that in this
video because if I talk about that in
this video it'll likely get banned for
harassing a self-professed political
activists because she's 16 years old
unlike the Covington kids so um yeah and
I get to get to YouTube there are a few
things that have been going on here and
at the time of recording this video
things are likely to change so I want to
be really clear about this and that's
what I want to get all of our our ducks
in a row when we we release some more
information tomorrow on the stream and
and you'll be learning at the same time
as I'll be learning the legal action
that we'll be taking with my handler
bill Richman a bit this this time of
sent him all of the the documentation
all the screenshots all the private
correspondence with YouTube and and by
the way my half agent Larry bill Richman
has corresponded with YouTube and Susan
Wojcicki he's met with her and spoken
with her so I don't really know what it
takes to get a clear answer on this um
one thing I will say before I move on to
any specifics if you haven't tuned out
now
but the best way to to follow this
content the best way to support if
you're not a member of mug club which is
what sustains us is listen we do a new
video every day every day except for
Sunday and sometimes on Sunday just
bookmark the page and check in every day
because subscriptions don't work and
then we get all of you to hit the
notification bill and then the majority
of you don't even get notifications and
now we've seen some stuff happening with
with search and this happens because
someone asked me about a chamber mine
video and I said well you just searched
even try to change my mind and right now
if you search it it's likely to change
because we'll be making enough of a
stink so if you're watching this video
two days later you might think that I'm
lying but at this very moment in time if
you search just even try to change my
mind then we're content shows up now it
will direct you to local CBS affiliates
it will direct you to Young Turks it'll
I think we're 70 search results down if
you type in my name as far as videos
that show up and it does get to be
frustrating because we've tried to act
in good faith and one thing I think that
conservatives get wrong when it comes to
YouTube so right now we're really
talking about the search algorithms the
organic traffic and them trying to sway
the election results for 2020 it's not
just about our channel but if they can
do what they've been doing to our
channel the biggest conservative YouTube
channel out there they're going to do it
with anyone they deemed to be a threat
and there are few other channels that
we've run searches on and we've seen
this happen right now we've seen organic
reach and search traffic direct people
away from conservatives and to other
channels we've also run these same
searches Diagnostics on leftist channels
and it's not happening it's not the same
treatment we've gone through the top
conservative channels top leftist
channels very very different search
results very different algorithms and
how they're treated very different
trends as far as organic region this all
coincides with YouTube making changes as
it relates to the verified channels you
know they came out publicly and said
we're going to try and encourage people
to or to redirect them rather to the
verified channels out there so that we
avoid imposters well we've experienced
the exact opposite of that to the power
we've experienced a decline for the
first time in four years several days in
a row and
again no answers so I mean this is one
of those things you tell me if my a
patient lawyer builders Bend meets with
Susan Wojcicki talks with her in the top
brass at Google and YouTube you know
they they pay our way our flights and
bring us out to a summit and say that
we're not violating any policies and
then go out publicly after the Vox and
pocalypse and say that we're not
violating any policies and then D
monetize us anyway which we knew but I
kind of warned that that was the tip of
the iceberg and what you would see was
was moreso the soft censorship behind
the scenes which i think is more
pervasive I think it's more dangerous
people know if you're demonetised people
know if you're banned right you can make
a stink about that what's harder is to
get people to see what's happening
beneath the surface which is complete
elimination of organic reach which is
the completely he disproportionately
applied policies to right-wing Channel
versus leftist channels and by the way
they're going to be new YouTube
harassment policies which there's an
article at CNBC right now that are
tributes it directly to me to this
channel to you really and the Vox ad
pocalypse that even if content out there
does not violate YouTube's policies
they're now going to expand the umbrella
to include more broad terms of
harassment so something I want to say
that I think conservatives have gotten
wrong I don't want to say wrong but I
think it's a miscalculation
strategically there's a lot of
conservatives go out there and if you
look at these lawsuits or people
complaining about you know censorship
they say well YouTube should and they
they go out and declare what they want
YouTube to be well YouTube should be
free and open YouTube should be a public
platform and they have try to declare
that they are a public platform but then
when they wanted to declare that their
publisher that being said it sue is
starting for a little bit of a deficit
because you are going out there making
the argument for what you want YouTube
to be they don't necessarily have to
play by those rules and I accept that
what we have been trying to do is hold
YouTube accountable to their own rules
YouTube goes out and says we don't we
don't manipulate search results they do
YouTube says we haven't affected your
subscriptions at all they have then we
get most of you to hit the notification
bill and
the majority of you don't get
notifications that's why I say please
just bookmark the page checking every
day
we don't want YouTube to be in charge of
us being in contact with you every day
on weekdays it's always at is it 8 p.m.
8 p.m. or 9 p.m. Eastern - goes up every
single day and then on Saturday we just
don't often do videos on Sundays so the
legal action that we're going to be
taking will go into more depth tomorrow
and will reveal more of this information
tomorrow as to what's happening and how
it affects you how it affects
conservatives how it affects the
election but I've gotten a lot of
questions from people hey why are you
still on YouTube or do you plan on
leaving YouTube or like I kick you off
YouTube - the last one I don't know they
very well make it yourself I don't think
that'll happen because they've openly
declared that we didn't violate any
policies but it's still possible as for
why I'm still on YouTube or often we
will get what sometimes we'll get
complaints and let's not here you might
hear the complaints why would you
support YouTube or big tech with your
business first off right now there's not
really an honest exchange of business
because they'd be monetized us now if
whatever it is Interscope Records
whoever owns Nirvana wants to falsely
copyright that and claim that that we've
unfairly used their content which of
course we haven't it's a parody all of a
sudden our content is monetizable and
family-friendly and they're collecting a
check but we can't do it ourselves I
[Music]
understand it I understand the argument
as to why we shouldn't be on YouTube and
that's why we do have a mug club and we
appreciate the support to those who
ordered mugs during the box at pocalypse
thank you I know we're a little bit late
on the mugs because it's such a huge
outpouring of support and I appreciate
you being patient you're gonna get your
wonderful girthy hand etched mug very
soon but um I'll be honest I've
considered leaving YouTube it's very
disheartening when you try to do
everything right and you're told that
you you didn't not just made this whole
team here that you're told you haven't
violated any policies you're told that
you followed the rules but they're gonna
target you anyway
that's tough anyone out there who runs a
business or who has a job you know
imagine going into your business and
someone else coming in and racking
I guess that might be like Bill Gates
circa 1995 when he was just wiping out
competitors and smashing their their
desks and their their desktops with
baseball bats I don't know don't quote
me on that I don't want to get sued
Brett is already upset please just
bookmark the channel so I have
considered but I'm not leaving YouTube
and let me tell you why
I'd be abandoning my post we've always
tried to use mug Club in your
subscriptions and your support which
does sustain us we make no money from
YouTube right now and of course the the
sponsors that come directly through
YouTube outside of our wonderful
sponsors like Walter and other sponsors
that come to our show directly we can
have no sponsorship agreements come
through YouTube so it is a little bit of
a squeeze but that's why mug club has
been designed we create more content
there you know the Daily Show for those
who don't know you don't get the full
show here on YouTube there's probably 70
80 percent more content there for those
remote Club members but by design we
never wanted to go on I never wanted to
go on YouTube create a show that you
guys like create content that you like
and then pull it away from you and put
it behind a paywall that's why we did
the hash tag never daily because for
people who follow this since the radio
days so this was a once a week show and
then when we went daily I wanted to make
sure that you had more free content than
ever back in the day we didn't do a
video every day on YouTube and that's
taken from the full show back in the day
you'd get one show a week and maybe one
other video in that week because my
priority is it isn't certainly not to
youtube and it's certainly not to but to
anyone other than my allegiance isn't is
in pledge to anyone other than you the
audience you the fan the person who
keeps the lights on who supports us and
I know that a lot of you out there can't
afford to maybe subscribe to mug club
right now you know $69 for a student can
be a lot of money I understand it so for
those people who have to be on youtube
we will be here as long as we possibly
can and we will fight for the ability to
be on this platform not because we think
that we're entitled to platform but
because YouTube has courted our business
and said we want you on the platform by
the way you're not violating any rules
what's happening now is YouTube
trying to sway an election and try it
frankly alter the political perceptions
of an entire generation you know
Generation Z is more conservative than
many generations to have come before it
now I know generation Z of course young
people are by and large liberal but if
you compare Generation Z to say the baby
boomers at that same age 16 years old 18
years old
or even the Gen Xers they are more
conservative and so YouTube now calls
that radicalization YouTube calls
changed my mind as you see by the search
results right now if you search steven
crowder changed my mind might change in
a couple days so don't hold me to that
and say that I'm alive you just might be
watching this a little bit later because
it lives on the internet forever but
YouTube considers that radicalization so
it doesn't show up steven crowder
changed mine 30 minutes completely
unedited with conversations with people
that couldn't possibly be more civil
that is filed under radicalization so I
want to stay on YouTube for as long as
humanly possible because I want to be a
part of what big tech views as the
problem I want to radicalize the youth I
want to radicalize the youth into
hosting their own change my minds I want
to radicalize the youth into supporting
the First Amendment and the Second
Amendment I want to radicalize the youth
in understanding the founding fathers in
their original intent for this country I
want to radicalize the youth in ensuring
that they don't feel alone or afraid
because they happen to have a political
opinion that might not be popular with
their professors the shows they watch or
everyone over there at big tech so is it
possible that within the next year we
get booted because some new arbitrary
rule is created that retro actively we
violated of course they keep moving the
goalposts does it upset me and what I
love to pull the biggest conservative
subscribership that's ever been on
YouTube from this godforsaken platform
absolutely but I'm not going anywhere as
long as there are new people to reach
and you folks out there supporting us so
please do bookmark the page tune in
tomorrow where we'll have the concrete
evidence and the legal action that will
be taking moving forward I'll talk about
what my half-asian lawyer bill Richman
and if you can afford it yeah I would
appreciate it you know if you you join
up at Mudd Club so that we don't lose
touch with you we never want you to be a
stranger
I hope that hope that illuminates a
situation a little bit and tomorrow hold
on to your butts